du job dating en plein champ c'est une
des nouveautés de cette édition 2010 8
d'inova lui 50 offres d'emplois sont à
pourvoir directement dans les différents
secteurs de l'agriculture
les entretiens recruteurs candidats
sanchez
nous recherchons actuellement plus de
quinze personnes de différents profils
techniciens assistants techniques
ingénieurs pour différentes horizon
production de semences sélection
marketing est sûre
toute la france la formation c'est le
commerce international et je cherche en
effet informations aussi en master 1
agroalimentaire et maintenant je viens
de terminer mais c'est tout en avant
l'immense terre et je cherche on pense
sur le marché international pourrait
comme chef de produit chez les marchés
ou et et des synthés reprise exportent
leurs produits à l'international
l'arrivée de nouvelles technologies en
agriculture a créé de nouveaux besoins
en matière de compétences et faire
coïncider offre et demande s'avère de
moins en moins évident c'est assez
compliqué aujourd'hui en agriculture sur
certains postes en de trouver des
des candidats sur certains profils sur
des soucis de localisation de postes et
des soucis de profils aussi qu'ils sont
pas forcément disponibles sur ces postes
là c'est jobdating ne se poursuivront
jusqu'à la fin du salon
et il est encore possible d'y participer